should you throw away your pad thai
if it's made by a white guy
and are we always racist even when we're
stuffing our faces
true they've ruined sports movies and
books now the woke are going after the
cooks an op-ed in the new york post
owned by our parent company arby's
says woke food lovers have lost their
minds over cultural appropriation it's
part of the woke plan to ruin everything
fun from eating to murder
it's true they've ruined murder too
the writer points to recent articles
calling out caucasian cooks who dare
make ethnic dishes not from their native
lands
someone better not tell them about
elizabeth warren's pow wow
remember that
all right i love that joke
they target the late diana kennedy a 99
year old british chef who pioneered
mexican cooking writes the new york
times she never reckoned with her
authority over mexican cuisine as a
white british woman
well too bad she's dead or she would
tell them to go eat a bag of spotted
dicks
by the way
by the way this is a spotted dick
[Laughter]
there's a lot of room in there jamie
i don't know whether to eat it or
eat it oh no so in their eyes the only
people who can make a taco are guys
named paco unless paco's from spain
and according to the times forget it if
you're a korean-born chef raised by
white people in america because your
korean food isn't korean enough proving
what i've said a million times adoption
doesn't work
that's what this segment is about
and celebrity chef jamie oliver a white
guy even hired cultural appropriation
specialist to give his menus the a-ok
making sure they don't offend anyone
here's jamie with his wife and kids
at least this jamie held it together
anyway
have the wokesters i went a long way for
that one i
googled searched a picture of his family
jamie got divorced
that's why i just like to rub it in
but have the wooster's gone too far
step right up free samples here yes
let's try our new diversitizer sounds
great
these are our tacos
what do you think
no mexicans were harmed in the making of
this taco
you shouldn't be eating this anyway
gringo that's right here we also have
hamburgers why don't you give that one a
try okay might as well
approved by german chefs just the way
you like it you nazi that's how you know
it's authentic uh we also have hot dogs
if you like to give that a try i mean
might as well right
this one actually tastes good but
why is there no message in it
nobody really knows it's inside hot dogs
anyway so you
know next please free samples
diversitizers
uh
tyrus could the argument be made that
cooking a foreign dish is honoring and
valuing a culture there is no argument
to be made yeah because
who are the morons eating it if you have
a hard time with it yeah why are you
going to a mexican restaurant if you're
not mexican stupid who wrote this what
[ __ ] show yourselves
america is a melting pot yes the food
and
[Applause]
[Music]
if you go to italy and ask for pizza and
you bite into it it doesn't taste like
our pizza yeah chinese food in america
doesn't taste like chinese food in china
because they care about the good food
over there
so the fact that you are literally
trying to be like a cultural
appropriation there's only one way
there's only one meal for them and it
tastes like the back of my hand you just
like that's what needs to happen
give me a break
everyone's mom has made their version of
chop suey meatloaf pizza we never had a
choice chop suey was always like a great
cartoon yeah and it was always the same
it always tastes like spaghetti but she
put a different name on it
cat you've never actually made a meal in
your life have you
it's been years yes
you remember the last thing you made i
made chili like two and a half years ago
not bad yeah not too bad right yeah
where's that from chili oh yeah chili
is it from chili i don't know it better
be it better because
yeah i did forget
the part in the cooking where you do the
cultural impact research
uh i just i don't see how this is a
problem but also the lengths to which
people are going like that british
cookbook author who's this expert on
mexican food she dies there's always all
these articles about she didn't reckon
with how she was a white lady who was an
expert at mexican food and it's like i
don't get how that's a problem at all
but it's certainly not a problem that
you can't get over even after someone
dies yeah that's like they see the
obituary they go no i need to add this
part like some grudges go beyond the
grave i get that but i don't think like
oh you're a white lady you made mexican
food burning hell [ __ ] like that just
seems
a lit like she you can let it go she she
died yeah she died let it let it be you
know you know jamie if i were to like
rent a really tiny car
drive to a mcdonald's order like a happy
meal sit in the like passenger seat of
the little car and eat it while kind of
crying would i be appropriating a
divorced dad
wow
i'm just
just trying to figure out who's driving
[Laughter]
um
i love greg i love when someone tells me
they're a foodie yeah that's a really
quick way of figuring out that i didn't
just make a new friend
um
[Laughter]
i hate the word i don't know why i hate
it so much yes
i hate the word and i get it it saves
time you know it's shorter than saying
fat pieces but it's um
am i
i'm not this is not a joke am i not
understand i don't understand where
whenever we have something from another
culture or growing up we're celebrating
and we're we're sharing you tell kids to
share and you i remember when i was a
kid we had like in school they had us
all get a recipe from a grandparent in
order to come and say like oh this is
what we did like what i don't understand
why where the offense comes from like
just because someone came over the first
like people don't you know you don't go
to taco bell and outside you see
protesters that are garbage men
we did the same thing when i was a kid
do you know what i mean though yeah yeah
yeah yeah we just said it's to celebrate
it yeah
you know you don't see
you don't see johnny devos out of a long
john silver you don't see um
i don't even know
what that means alex though this is
always a trend whether it's sports or
movies or now it's food it's like wokism
is is to move away from the primary
purpose make sports
fun or when now it's about like
providing equity for trans or they try
to do something and now with food it's
like it's not important that it tastes
good is that you don't hurt the ancestry
or something i don't know
whenever i whenever i'm like forced to
consider an issue like this it's just
another example of just like
uh
radical first world access just gone
totally off the rails and like um you
know the world is like just laughing at
us for even having these conversations
and um
every time i think about like discussing
it i feel like my iq goes down a couple
points
so i mean
yeah people can get mad about food or
whatever but that's just i have i'm too
busy dude yes
oh it is racist
they took our identity away from us and
we had to invent food
so racist ass
letter
hey where do you think ribs and all that
good stuff the sweet potato pie came
from we invented it
cultural that
there we go
once again
by ending a sentence with that word
thank you it makes it all right it has a
regressive meaning component to it
making it instantly more valuable
you learning my brother i know
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else